I'm joined today by Graham Allison who's
the Douglas Dylan professor of
government at the Harvard Kennedy School
of Government our topic today is China a
professor you know I read a lot in sort
of popular media about when will if
China will become the world's superpower
but there's a sort of other approach to
that which is that by some measures one
could argue China is already the
superpower can you talk a little bit
about that and how we might evaluate
such a claim well it's a great question
Americans all know in our bones that we
are number one
so it's a very yet almost inconceivable
for most of us that some other power
should rival us or even surpass us in
many domains in fact in the book that
I've this recently published called
destined for work and the US and Janet
escape lucidity strap I give two tables
that I present to my students at Harvard
in my class and the first one which says
when could China become number one and
in my class I have 26 indicators in the
book I just have a condensed version so
when could China become the largest
middle class the largest number of
billionaires the largest producer of
computers the fastest supercomputers the
larger the the event the most advanced
artificial intelligence the largest
economy in the world
so students guess 2030 2040 not in my
lifetime then I make him look at a
second chart the heading of which is
already already all those things have
happened the China already has the
largest middle class bigger than the
whole American population China already
has the most billionaires China already
is the largest producer of computers
China already wins the contest for the
fastest supercomputer China is already
the largest economy in the world
measured by what both the IMF and the
CIA regard is the single best yardstick
for
preparing national economies which is
purchasing power parity that was the big
takeaway from the IMF World Bank meeting
in Washington in 2014 but most of us
miss it
very good so in hearing you say this
some in our audience might say wow I
must really be not just so just very
unaware of all of the data that points
to China being the superpower in the
world right now there is also the
possibility that there's something that
is not maybe measurable in some of those
statistics that we might be able to
flesh out that might tell us more about
the concept of a superpower so just as
like one example and I'm really curious
to hear your thoughts on it there is the
argument that some make which is that
looking at the size of China's economy
or even purchasing power parity and some
other economic indicators it doesn't
consider for example China's relatively
undeveloped financial sector and that
consumption of goods because you have a
huge population and manufacturing
capacity is one thing but that the
superpower dumb for lack of a better
term also relates to the influence of a
country's financial sector
geopolitically what about something like
that or those critiques valid in your
mind I would say yes that the I would
not not argue that China has surpassed
the US in every dimension for example
military balance where I would say we
continue to have in some domains 10
yearly than some domains maybe even a 20
year lead in the financial arena another
very interesting question in case now
Chinese would say well yes the US is the
center of international finance and the
US has liberalized open financial
liberalized open financial system and
that's actually been the recurring cause
of collapses like the collapse of 2008
2009 which was actually you know started
in Wall Street that we Chinese they
would say are not going to liberalize
Eric our finance we maintain more state
control of it in order to push it
ourselves again
such consequences and in fact I mean if
you look and see what happened in 2009
and 2009 the US economy declined as a
result of the Great Recession and China
did not so there's a little bit there
the US with the American dollar as the
international currency has a great
advantage internationally as the
currency of last resort so people like
countries like China hold a trillion and
a half dollars of American paper so
basically we take paper we put a stamp
on it and people take it as if it was as
good as gold well that's because we're
the reserve currency that gives us
another significant advantage over time
will China help and is it we're seeking
to have its currency the RMB become a
second or third currency and even then a
rival currency that's that's over time
so I would say them and and similarly in
per capita income another measure so the
Chinese have a good economy the total
economy of which is bigger than ours but
they have four times as many people so
that means people that are 1/4 the per
capita GDP so per capita GDP again is
another measure relevant for some
purposes so if I were making as I do in
my course I would say there's no single
metric for measuring nations they
compete in many many different
dimensions but we should notice that in
many relevant dimensions where Americans
would believe that we were number one
because we've always been number one in
our memory and lifetime we now have a
serious rival yeah and I think that
you're getting at something which is
sort of what I want to talk about next
which is the characteristics that
portray geopolitical power seem to be
different than some of these internal
metrics that you cited I mean can you
talk a little bit about when we think
about geopolitical power what metrics
might we look at there or are they more
qualitative rather than quantitative
well extremely good questions I don't
I get it if I were exploring it in my
class it would take a whole a whole
quest but let me try to just do the cup
of a few icebergs here so basically
economics is the substructure for power
in international politics if a country
is bigger and stronger than another that
doesn't mean it will necessarily be more
powerful in every dimension but as Damon
Runyon would say that was the that's the
way to bet it so as China has become the
biggest economy it's also become the
biggest importer and the biggest
exporter so if you look for example
around the South China Sea at the
countries that are organized at a unit
called ASEAN so this would be Thailand
the Philippines Malaysia Indonesia
Singapore these countries now find
themselves attached to the gravity in
effect of a larger Chinese economy which
is their number one trading partner as a
consequence particularly because China
plays hardball in geo-economics it
squeezes them when it doesn't like
something that they're doing to the
point that they comply so this is a
place where even though it's not just
the raw comparison if if you're my
number one market and you're prepared to
close your market for me for example if
I'm the Philippines and I sell you
bananas and you'll just let them sit
there on the dock and rot until the
point that I give in to you Lord the
whole I become more compliant so that's
on that space on the other hand if you
ask where does Chinese students want to
go study they want to go study work if
they have an opportunity in the US as do
students from all over the rest of the
world does that provide a significant
advantage for the u.s. in the sense that
then people come here they see what a
free society is they see our society and
many of the things that they like about
it they also see some of the ugly parts
of our society but still in a democratic
society like ours at least we would work
as as we should do we find our mistakes
we try to correct the mistakes we're
perfectly prepared to debate the
mistakes so I think that in general if
you offer people a chance to be more
free or less free what I like to have
somebody else telling me which whether I
can go to Google and what sites I can go
to and whether I can read this or that
no I wouldn't but in China they manage
to control the information or tried
their best to control information
accessible to people so I think this
many this is a very complex calculation
as you try to think about all of the
dimensions of power and influence do you
have any feelings one way or the other
as to how if at all the perception or
reality and pick either or both to
address of the United States as a world
superpower has shifted during the nine
months of the current administration
well I think the good question I think
that the first point is to put this in
context so long before Donald Trump
arrived in Washington Washington was
regarded as dysfunctional we should
remember that the Congress has not been
able to pass a budget you know for nine
years so this functionality is not new
to Washington Donald Trump and to some
extent and his administration is a
expression of a political system that's
not working very well but the
combination of the two lead people in
other countries for example China which
has just had its big 19th Party Congress
one of the things they say that Chinese
is looking look at the US and see the
way it governs itself or fails to do so
and ask would you rather not have a
competent group of people running the
railroad and I would say that's a good
argument actually for the first time
ever this was interesting at the party
Congress last week Chinese had been very
reserved about holding out the their
form of leadership in the society and
governance which is basically a party
led
miel authoritarian structure in which
the citizens and everybody else's rights
are confined and constrained and guided
and when by the party well that's not
our system and they said generally have
been really reserved about saying well
we don't we don't have they would say we
don't have a model we just try to govern
ourselves we're a developing country
this first time in GCN brings work plan
this big plan that he laid out last week
he says actually the Chinese model may
appeal to many countries we're trying to
get wealthier the way we have done so
look and see what we've done in terms of
our development and compare this with
what other societies that have been
trying to govern themselves more
according to American principles have
done so I would say that's a that's an
element of the of the answer to your
question we've been speaking with
Professor Graham Allison the Douglas
Dylan professor of government at the
Harvard Kennedy School of Government up
the road from us professor thanks so
much for talking to us today thank you
so much for having me